grew up in the San Gabriel Valley
predominantly like Chinese you know and
Mexican area I kind of went through a
lot of struggles with like bullying and
just gang banging and you guys are from
the area you know late 90s early 2000s
ended up going to Hawaii which is like
the worst of the worst um is that like
juvie it's like a child's prison you can
be 10 until 25. children that's
committed parkour so it's like the
Harvard but on the other side it's
called Uh Youth Authority Right
congratulations
from that that oh I ended up going to
prison and then after that I came out
and changed my life through like
Ministry basically Christianity what
part of sgv you grew up in the gang that
I was around was in Monterey Park in
Alhambra so was ours as the true sgv
person because everyone always argues
these things do you consider Arcadian
the sgv
dang maybe even Alhambra like and north
of Maine
come on